hi I was gonna ask - welcome to Peter
Pike waste 2016 uh you bro send me this
online and yeah it's a quiz on how well
I know a pro tip I I'm pretty sure I
know myself all right
I don't think anyone else can tell me
how I know me so I expect a 10 out of 10
let's do this
what is PewDiePie's intro in all his
videos well let's see if I can remember
obviously this how's it going bros my
name is beautiful
yes [ __ ] yes
alright doing good so far see if we can
keep up number two what's the name of
Peter PI's black puck and what's my name
what's my [ __ ] name rich is it
my app no is it Edgar it's it's eight it
might as well be it might have [ __ ]
well be Satan or Hitler okay it's it's
Edgar Edgar correct alright cool cool so
far how old is Peter pine well I look
[ __ ] 21 in this picture Jesus Christ
how old is that 26 or twelve [ __ ] you
all right actually I do look 12 in I
think I'm 26
[ __ ] you
all right bunny ha ha I'm not 12 all
right why does Peter pie call his left
testicle I don't have a name for it to
be honest
lease at ok sergeant Bulls me
or left testicle I'm gonna have to go
with left testicle because that's
probably what I would call my left wrong
Peter pie doesn't have any balls
[ __ ] you what do you think of the
questions so far yeah I'll tell you what
I think of the [ __ ] questions
they are awesome or they suck well they
suck
obviously Peter pie sucks all right fine
I'm gonna get all the rest one right
don't even worry about it
what is - push - what does that even do
with me genital herpes or four four
correct genital hop what the [ __ ] that
isn't even me is PewDiePie a man-child
screaming little [ __ ] yes yes or
absolutely absolutely
correct they're all correct okay funny
funny how many times has peed if I swore
in his video like I would know that a
lie wait 6180 9 or 9 what if I swear now
and then click 6 [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me all right
this is getting [ __ ] weird
how many nipples just put if I have the
same [ __ ] a lot and impossible what
does that even mean a lot I don't know
what which one is worse said like a two
here somewhere hiding or some [ __ ] I
miss [ __ ] nostril in his me a lot
wrong impossible that on [ __ ] even
[ __ ] [ __ ] what does impossible mean
what does it mean last question is
PewDiePie a potato Yes No maybe
oh [ __ ]